I'm sorry sometimes you contributed to
it sometimes you did things that drove
him to do that and women take no
accountability for that they take no
accountability for the fact they won't
sleep with their husbands they take no
accountability for the fact they put on
a bunch of weight and I'm not talking a
little bit of baby weight I'm talking 40
50 pounds there's no excuse for that
they don't take accountability for the
fact that they don't appreciate their
husbands that they may get a living hell
when he comes home and that he wants to
go to the bar with his buddies because
you make that a hell hole because
you are so unpleasant to be around
and that man forgives you for all of
that but you can't forgive him for
stepping out once
twice you guys are you guys are crazy